Well that time we got it right but suppose we made a mistake.
Suppose we had access to the global environment
so this is actually defined,
and instead of passing in the current environment,
whenever we make a function, we're going to pass in the global environment instead.
This is a bug. This is not correct.
Let's try to reason forward about what might go wrong,
and how we could see this bug or how it would behave.
I'm going to write some statements and you're going to tell me which ones are true.
Here I've written four claims, and in this multiple choice test
I'd like you to note which ones are true.
The first, no test input with only one function can show the bug.
The second, we need at least three variables
in the global environment to see the bug.
Here--see the bug, show the bug, expose the bug--all mean the same thing.
We can show the bug with only two functions,
each of which is separately declared at the top level,
and finally, we can show the bug with one function nested inside another function.